so while today is technically our
classic DC day we did tighten so we have
our classic DC video out of the way I
was only going to upload one and then
the teaser trailer dropped for Black
Panther and so now we're going to cover
do more this story is amazing do more so
good it's really one of my favorite
stories but there is a little bit of
exposition that goes into the story in
terms of setting things up now
technically there's a prelude but the
prelude lasts something like 15 issues
and we're not going to cover all 15
issues instead all it really happened
here is that in the history of Wakanda
has always been extremely isolated and
its high distractions in lanes I mean
Black Panther has always played a role
in a larger superhero community like he
was an Avenger he was married to I guess
is married to storm of the x-men I mean
he's always had this sort of going on in
terms of being part of the greater world
if for no other reason than to just
monitor the greater world in order to
make sure they never become a threat to
Wakanda but what had happened was a
black panther has sustained an injury
and he had handed control over to his
sister Cherie and so she allegedly
became the new black panther after
undergoing trials and T'Challa was
really more of like a warrior spotter
yellow slash I guess political
counsellor more so than anything else
but he was so considered to be like the
protector of Wakanda it was kind of a
weird situation it was almost like a
two-in-one ruling party but what had
happened was the idea come to fruition
of Wakanda stepping more into the
greater world and basically play more of
a role and the otherworldly politics the
problem with this is that there was a
group called the destory
and the destroyer were basically like
these radicals that will even more of a
fundamentalist traditional approach in
the sense that what conduct had to
remain isolated and had to stay away
from everything and so what had happened
is that through unknown means the
disturbing received some kind of backing
some kind of political support and it
resulted in them launching a coup d'etat
and I'll sting Cherie and black panther
which meant that it put them in control
of Wakanda and so what they had done is
they had also put their guys all
throughout the city and so you never
knew if the person that you were talking
to was this a regular wakandan or if
they were part of the history forces and
so again it's created a lot of
resentment and a lot of distrust but
what we ended up finding out here was
that the backer of the entire coup
d'etat was dr. doom himself
and the reason why was because dr. doom
wanted nothing more than they capture
all the vibranium in Wakanda now
industry didn't really understand the
value of vibranium they didn't really
understand exactly what it is they had
they did to a degree but in terms of
what it meant for their placement it
didn't really matter because for them
they wanted to remain isolated so if
they got rid of all the other vibranium
or if they lost it all then what it
would also do is would allow them to
stay further isolate the problem with
this was that they didn't really know
the motivations of dr. doom dr. doom
back to their COO and they didn't really
care about vibranium but at the end of
the day it would also keep them wealthy
so it was this motivation to keep it as
well but doom by going in and basically
setting things up creating a huge
distraction and creating a civil war and
inner turmoil in the form of a rebellion
when in turn allow him to basically
sneak in the backdoor and steal the
vibranium out of Wakanda the problem
with this is that vibranium is wakanda's
number one source of anything it's how
they make their money is what makes them
so valuable so it's not like they have
it just sitting under the mattress I
mean they have it you know hidden behind
lock and key it's behind the vault with
a multitude of security safes now the
other half of this is that because storm
was married or is married to Black
Panther and because Black Panther and
fury were able to make their escape this
last storm a political prisoner of war
and as a leader really has come like the
queen of Wakanda this resulted in her
being put on trial with a sentence of
execution now of course because she's an
x-man this immediately sends a black
panther over to the x-men asking for aid
and this happens for two major reasons
the first is because of the fact that is
the x-men like mutants are the most
powerful group on the planet I mean the
wide array of powers that I possess
everything from reality warping and so
on and so forth there's a lot of things
that they can do the other half of this
is that he simply just needs eight he's
only needs help and they will come to
the rescue of storm or at least it's
believed that they would the problem
with this is that remember this is
fallout of house of M now we are going
to start over on the x-men and we are
going to cover everything between the
to them and probably the end of schism
to be honest but this is the point at
which Cyclops cannot risk the numbers of
the x-men taking them to war means that
there will probably be casualties and if
there will be casualties it means that
the number of the mutants that exist
right now will begin to decrease because
remember their numbers only at around
198 give or take a few here and there
EXO because of this the initial response
of Black Panther I'm sorry of Cyclops is
to say no we cannot help you but it's
genius the way this is done because
website cop says is publicly I cannot
support you publicly I cannot come out
and say we as the x-men Ally ourselves
with with with white anther because this
is now an international incident all
eyes are on Wakanda to see what happens
next
but because of the fact of the x-men
have to stay neutral for the protection
they received from the office of
national emergency which was design in
which booth was really launched for the
purpose of making sure nobody attacked
the x-men because there's so few mutants
left cytoxan turn says while I can't
really publicly support you I can't stop
on to people from following what it is
they want to do if what they happen to
want to do is side with you and invade
Wakanda and save SCORM well Who am I to
stand in their way it's just if
political maneuvering it's nothing more
than political maneuvering and it's
genius it's really kind of highlight the
genius level of Cyclops as a leader now
the other half of this is that this is
really kind of us getting a little bit
of a run over in terms of what Wakanda
is about remember the Black Panther clan
formed as a byproduct of vibranium crash
landing in Wakanda and then in turn the
shingu basically creating a kind of a
protected group that would serve the
purpose of making sure that nobody ever
access to that vibranium which is really
kind of where Wakanda began to grow and
began to evolve and we're really the
money they receive from from vibranium
and the ability to send all their
students to some of the best schools on
the planet the intelligence they have is
what makes Wakanda so technologically
advanced more so than virtually any
other city on the planet so again in the
middle of all this we actually end up
having dr. doom break into the prisoner
break into the cell where storm is being
held and free her now the funny thing
about this is that initially we would
believe that this would be dr. doom
being altruistic saying hey look you
know I'm going to do the right thing I'm
going to help storm but what ultimately
ends up happening here
if he actually turns against storm to a
degree and says the only reason why I
freed you is because you were a thief
when you were a kid and as if the you
are very good at like cracking safes and
different things like that you are going
to crack the safe that's going to get me
into what if Iranians at so I can steal
it and that's kind of a cool thing
because what we have are two different
situations happening at the same time
it's all these different forces of you
know of like Panthers Royal Guard that
is to say that women who are the most
prodigious spiders on the planet you
know being led by a Shariah sister
Sheree as well as whatever x-men have
come along in addition to Doctor Doom
trying to crack into the safe now of
course things in click fast and in a
hurry with regard to this mystery they
get brought down super fast of course
Nightcrawler teleports Black Panther and
Sheree in and they immediately execute
all the heads of the of the destory I
mean they're brought down and so from
that point it's really just kind of
cutting the head off the snake and it
turns into a little bit of a panic in a
sense of it's like well now all they
have to do is go through and kill what's
left of the destory there will be some
who will who will stay their guns they
will maintain their ideals their
philosophies and they'll say we need to
remain isolated and they'll basically
just kind of stay hidden until such a
time that they can remonster their
forces and strike again but most would
just run they would just flee they would
say well there's no one to lead us
anymore they would just take off either
they would leave Wakanda or they would
abandon their ideals and they would just
blend in and nobody would ever know they
were part of the mystery in the first
place but the other half of this is that
an order for storm to achieve her goal
remember she's a very strong and
prominent woman really only the highest
of threats would force her into his
situation she doesn't want to be in and
that's exactly what doom does he takes
the mother of black panther and says I'm
going to execute her if you do not open
this safe not only that not only will I
kill her I will come after your
livelihood and the livelihood of anyone
you've ever met and I'll kill everybody
in the city of Wakanda I don't care but
what dr. doom has to gain is far more
than what he would have to lose at the
hands of all these different people who
show up and so at this point you know
with the distri having been defeated
it's now a war on two fronts it's
eliminating those individuals who are
left but it's also black panther trying
to take out dr. doom now this is kind of
a cool thing about this because with
black panther what's the charla being so
smart it's not enough to
just put locks I mean anybody can crack
locks with enough time they can crack
locks dr. doom if given enough time
would be able to open these the last
lock so to speak is basically something
by purity and it comes in the form of a
riddle it says only through purity
unencumbered by pretense may you pass
now on the surface and even we as people
would have no idea what that means but
remember this is Victor Von Doom he Reed
Richards and Valeri Richards routinely
it's you know change place as the three
most intelligent people on the planet
and you know this combined with his
knowledge of sorcery and magic and so on
and so forth means it's only a matter of
time before he figures out exactly what
it is that he has to do and so what ends
up happening here is that by the time
Black Panther arrives
dr. doom has thrown captive gives storm
the Black Panther disappears and the
vibranium is gone which begs the
question how did you get it how did he
access it and so at this point the other
half of the equation is okay where did
dr. doom go now and this is when we
basically start invoking the entirety of
the superhero community because remember
this is dr. doom so the Fantastic Four
are his most notable enemies and it
makes sense that that T'Challa would go
to the Fantastic Four
especially Reed Richards and say look
dr. doom stole all the vibranium we need
to bring him down now keep in mind the
reason why vibranium is so important is
because of the fact that in addition to
what kind of being the only place where
you can find what condon vibranium you
can find it in the Arctic but it's not
nearly as capable vibranium from Wakanda
amplifies magical energy which means
that those individuals who use magical
power and who access vibranium can
amplify their own magical energy
effectively dr. doom can multiply his
power tenfold now in addition to there's
something else to keep in mind is that
we also have a guy named Walter del Caen
who's basically the broker now this is
not a new character back during the
events of civil war one of the things
that we have found out one of the
reasons why it had happened was because
of the fact that there was the villain
nitro who had blown up Stanford
Connecticut yada yada yada but Walter
Dalton was the head of a company called
damage controls Incorporated which had a
government contract to clean up cities
after superheroes had engaged in
conflict with supervillains what Dell
can had done is he was basically going
through and he was engineering conflicts
with
superheroes and villains for the purpose
of securing an increase in government
contracts the more conflicts they were
the more he could bargain he could say
well things are worse now than they were
before so you should pay us more if you
want us to start cleaning up these
cities otherwise we're not going to and
so again it was really just greed that
kind of got the better of them but for
the most part right now he just serves
as this sort of financial backer but not
really financial backer kind of like a
broker for for Victor Von Doom and this
simply he's the guy that kind of manages
his money
besides whereas money to spin out that
kind of thing but as long as on to make
sure that the money of Victor Von Doom
never runs out but what we end up
finding out here is the way the dr. doom
was able to access the vibranium in the
first place was that he appeared before
the Panthers of the Panther god fast and
that's why this story so cool and that's
why I wanted to cover it because it
literally hit every important mark of
the Black Panther mythos and Marvel
Comics the Panther got bass is the God
or even goddess of us I you want to
interpret because as far as I'm aware a
bass is really kind of viewed as like a
female but as a God it's male and
females however it wants to appear to
any particular person but bass is the
one that basically bestows the Black
Panther with their powers so all the
powers of the chawla has his enhanced
speed his agility you know all that kind
of good stuff that all comes from the
Panther God now of course when a new
Black Panther is chosen they have to
undergo a trial they have to expose
themselves they have to step humbly
before bast and were to prove their
intention the fact that their goal is
for the betterment of Wakanda and to
make sure that that his vibranium is
safeguarded
but with Victor Von Doom appearing
before bass he does that exact same
thing but what he says is the world is
rife with conflict the world is rife
with petty Wars the world is rife with
people who squabble over nonsensical
things what I want to do is take the
vibranium amplify my own power secure my
rule and make sure that the world
becomes stable I'm going to impose my
will on the world I'm going to make it
my own now of course the funny thing
about this is that we would expect that
to say that's ridiculous I'm not going
to let you use it for your own selfish
means but this is this is Victor Von
Doom being altruistic you cannot lie to
the Panther God best it'll see into your
soul for who you are and it'll know
whether you're lying or not
as really just kind of one of these
scenarios where doom has to be honest
and the honest truth about him is
despite all his villainy and despite all
his evil he's trying to make the world a
better place albeit under his absolute
control which kind of makes sense you
know if freedom leads to the destruction
of humanity then of what used was
freedom to humanity in the first place
and so again it's kind of an interesting
scenario because ultimately the Pampa
God Bass approves doctor dooms actions
which allowed him to access the
vibranium in the first place and so with
this in mind what this does is it
invokes the entirety of the superhero
community or most every single person
who's out there just because of the fact
that Victor Von Doom now has this
vibranium
he's enhanced his own doombots these
robots that he's created for himself
with vibranium enhanced magic which
means that now they're more powerful
than they ever were before and doom is
more powerful than he's ever been before
and so the funny thing about this is
that what this does is highlight the
intelligence of T'Challa because while
the Incredible Hulk is involved and
while you know the Fantastic Four and
the x-men and you know war machine James
wrote while all these guys are involved
and engaged in the purpose of destroying
the doombots of Doctor Doom - Charla
kind of thinks about this for a second
and says the one thing doom would expect
is for us to just come charging in or as
for the entire superhero community to
become involved what we need is an
unstable element what we need is a
variable we need someone that Doctor
Doom would never expect to see get
involved in this conflict and so what he
does is he hires Deadpool's black
panther hires deadpool and sounds like
your job your task is to infiltrate this
entire building to gain access and then
to try to find a way to either prove
that Doom stole the vibranium put a
device on it or something along those
lines or to basically give us a way to
locate the vibranium so we can teleport
it out he's really just kind of engaging
with infiltration now the funny thing
about this is we would never expect to
see Deadpool hired by five black
panthers half the reason for this is
because of the fact that the midnight
angels who are like the inner circle
they're the best trained female warriors
really the best trained warriors in
Wakanda when they meet Deadpool Deadpool
hits on a ball
a little more which is kind of funny
there's one of those because those funny
little moments that we get but the fact
remains you I mean again this is
everybody facing you have a facing off
against all these doom box because under
normal circumstances it wouldn't really
matter in a normal circumstance doom box
could just be taken out you know at any
point in time it's not really relevant
but because the fact that these doom
bots are magically enhanced then what
this does is it creates more of a
scenario where the superheroes have to
fight together more so than they did
before the other half of this is that
the entire ability for doom to basically
wages war hinders on his financial
holdings so one of the cool things that
happens is surely the sister of Black
Panther hacked into his bank accounts
and then basically siphons all his funds
away and just donate some to charities
and all that kind of good stuff but
again it's basically taking all the
things that Doctor Doom cares about now
keep in mind all this is designed for
the purpose of winding things down with
a character a Victor Von Doom setting
the stage for Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and new Avengers for him to be
you know to play a major role in that
and to have a vested interest in being
part of that whole scenario and so what
is it happening here is with doom you
know of course capturing Deadpool and so
on and so forth and doing basically
heart you know hooking himself up to all
this power all this vibranium and
effectively turning himself into a god
Doom can now do virtually anything he
wants to because now all the magic that
he has is being amplified several times
over by the vibranium that he's enhanced
himself with and so every particle of
magic everywhere every particle of metal
everywhere is now under dooms control
he's almost like magneto pushed to the
extreme in terms of his powers combined
with the magics and sorcery and so on
and so forth and so it's kind of insane
because ultimately doom does not really
have it I mean he none of the
superheroes have a chance that's
basically what's going on here what do
they face off against doom whatever it
is they do it's all a stopgap measure
this conflict will go on only for so
long and their numbers will dwindle
people will be reduced down there'll be
nobody left and every last one of them
will be defeated and so what ends up
happening here is T'Challa does the only
thing he can do in order to defeat
Victor Von Doom if Victor Von Doom is
powered by vibranium and the only way to
defeat Victor Von Doom is to strip him
of the vibranium
but Victor Von Doom is
the vibranium itself then you have to
destroy the source of its power and
that's what white panther does he
effectively renders all vibranium across
the planet completely inert he destroys
his source of income there's no more
vibranium on the planet that's worth
anything every ounce of vibranium across
the world is just a chunk of metal and
so at this point Doctor Doom has no
basis for his power being as advanced as
it is he just kind of reduced back to
his normal self
and then at this point that's really it
I mean that's really all there is
there's just dr. doom and he's just
attained you know he's basically
harnessed by via various superheros of
the world of course he's worn by Shuri
that if he ever comes back to Wakanda
don't kill him no questions asked and
then at that point it's just kind of the
rebuilding phase of Wakanda that's
really it I mean that's really all there
is to it but again you know this
basically set the stage for like
Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers with
the idea of why it is - black panther
why why wakandan vibranium is gone why
Wakanda is scant broke this sets the
stage for why Shuri remains alive
Panther because despite the fact that
T'Challa saved his people
he almost betrayed them because now
their source of wealth is gone all it is
is just what Conda and that's it there's
nothing more I miss is one of the
reasons why it is that of course black
panther ends up going with the
Illuminati you know and trying to stop
the incursions and so on and so forth
but any of that guys if you are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like one of
my favorite stories absolutely love
doing more it's super action-packed it's
not really one of those storytelling
kind of things it's just like crazy
things are happening there's one of my
favorite stories but anyway guys we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]